where's the source of alarmism
so is it the ipcc the intergovernmental
panel on climate change like what
there's a chain here is there somebody
to blame along the chain or is this some
kind of weird complex as to where
everybody encourages each other can you
point to one place is it the media is it
the scientist I think the U.N climate
panel is fundamentally a really good uh
uh uh climate research group that you
can have some quipples with the way that
they sort of summarize it and
politically coordinated documents and
stuff but you know fundamentally I think
they do a good job of of putting
together all the research this also
means it's incredibly boring to read
which is why virtually Nobody Does it
I'm I'm sure you have but I'm pretty
sure a lot of climate journalists have
never sort of looked past the uh at
least the uh the summary for policy
making climate panel they do like us
they do predictions as well well they
they pull together all the stuff that
people have have published in the period
literature and then try to summarize it
and basically tell you so what's up and
down with climate change they do that in
four four large volumes every four to
five six seven years or something uh and
um and yes it's it's you know I think
it's the gold-plated version of what we
know uh there tends to be a lot of
um uh well this is what they say
actually they say so many different
places with so many different people
that it's not quite clear exactly what
they're saying often you know you can
sort of find contradictions between one
volume with one set of authors and
another but yeah look I I think this is
fundamentally the right way that we know
about climate but then it gets
translated into how do you how do you
know about this when most people don't
read these 4 000 Pages you read a new
story in a newspaper and that new story
will be very very heavily slanted
towards you know if if you say so sea
levels could rise somewhere between one
and three foot what do you hear yeah you
obviously hear the three foot three foot
is just you know more fun more scary
more interesting than one foot uh and
and it's that way with all of these you
know so what what's the prediction for
for temperature arises it's uh somewhere
from not very scary to pretty damn scary
uh and again you hear the pretty damn
scary all the time uh and and then
there's there's obviously always
researchers who are saying well but
actually it could be a little more scary
than that and then they're likewise
researchers who say well you know it's
probably not going to be as scary as
that and most of the journalists will
you know interview do you really put the
blame fundamentally on the on the
journalists on the media setup look
media is simply trying to get clicks or
sell newspapers and if if you were just
going to say this is not a big issue it
just doesn't sell anything but I think
you're probably much better able to
address this well no I
folks can Google for my name revkin and
the words front page thought
in The Newsroom
every afternoon now we have a 24 7 News
cycle so it's different but
back in the day of the New York Times
when it was a flourishing print
institution every afternoon there was a
front page meeting and the big Pupa
editors go in there and the desk editors
come in with their pitches for the day
and my friend Corey Dean who is the
science editor for chunk of my time
uh you know I remember having a
conversation with her about some new
study of I think it was Greenland the
ice sheet and I laid it out for her and
she said where's the front page thought
in that
so we're all set up to look for the
that's scary but and the News
environment has gotten so much worse
than than 10 or 20 years ago at least
you had filters and
limited number of outlets and there was
some sense you could track what's good
or bad there's lots of problems with
that system too but now you have an
information Buffet so if you're if you
want to be alarmed or you want to be con
stay in the tribe of those who think
this is utterable you can find your flow
and that that has led
but getting back to this specific
question I think the 2018 ipcc report
which was a special report commissioned
to learn about the difference between
1.5 degrees of warming and two which
sounds so weird and technocratic and
complicated that's the one that
generated the whole meme about eight
years left 12 years
and that's the one this was the uh the
idea that there's a point we're gonna if
we don't
cut emissions in half by whatever it was
2015. we're doomed that emerged from
that specific report and it wasn't
something that was in the report it was
in the spin around the report and that's
what captivated Greta appropriately as a
young person going you know and with her
unique vantage point and stuff and that
report I still need to dig in and write
something deeper about
what happened with that particular
Dynamics created this recent burst of
resumed rhetoric that that I think
you're focusing on and it's all in the
external interpretations which
journalism laps up
because we're looking for the front page
thought but it's not just the
journalists it's the whole system uh
ngos environmental groups if you're if
in developing country uh well-meaning
leaders in developing countries
because of the structure of this treaty
that goes back to 1992 that's the Paris
agreement is part of
they are now um
really looking for a way to portray this
as a CO2 problem not a vulnerability
well there's a vulnerability aspect but
like in Pakistan they're they're um
climate Minister which they didn't even
have a climate Minister five years ago
is blaming everything that happened in
Pakistan on carbon dioxide warming the
climate creating this when a lot of what
was going on was also on the ground and
you can blame colonialism Pakistan's
history all kinds of things
but but under the treaty you want it to
be about CO2 because that puts the onus
on rich countries you're not paying us
where's our money and they're right you
know in the context of what everyone
agreed to there was supposed to be 100
billion dollars a year
from rich countries to poor countries
starting in 2020 it didn't happen it's
like basically
some money is Flowing but it's not
really made up of money yeah and so so
that whole dynamic
they latch onto the climate science and
they they you know so they're there and
they're very handy quotable people
and you have a Justice angle you have
bad guys and good guys
which fits all these narrative threads
that come together into this information
storm we're still living with and and
then of course it's not Pakistan's fault
either right I mean it also actually
almost all leaders now say it's because
of climate because then it's not you
know we didn't do anything wrong uh in
Germany for instance uh when we had that
flood last year it's it's not impossible
that the climate had a part in in that
but it's very very clear that the main
reason why so many people died in
Germany and Belgium was because the
Alarm Systems didn't work and this was
plainly the local leaders in Germany now
if I'm stuck here and basically have
caused the you know the death of 200
people would I rather say yeah that's on
me or what I climate it's just such an
easy scapegoat I don't want to place it
all in the journalists I think because
there's a lot of if I were to think
about what did you call it front page
thought there's a lot of really
um
narratives that uh result in destruction
of the human species so nuclear war
pandemics all that kind of stuff it
seems that climate is a sticky one so
the fact that it's sticky means there's
other interests at play like you guys
are talking about in terms of politics
all that kind of stuff so it's not just
the journalists I feel like journalists
will try anything for the front page but
it won't you won't stick unless there is
bigger interest to play for which these
narratives are useful so journalists
will just throw stuff out there and see
if it gets clicks and sure
um it all it's it's like a first Spark
maybe uh this is maybe a tiny Catalyst
of the initial stuffs but it has to be
picked up by the politicians by interest
groups and all that kind of stuff